with that let's start with our panel
expanded tonight fox news senior
political analyst brit hume ben dominic
publisher of the federalist trey gowdy
former congressman from south carolina
and harold ford jr former tennessee
congressman ceo of empowerment and
inclusion capital brett let me start
with you
it seems like
always speaker pelosi has pulled a
rabbit out of a hat when it comes to
legislation but these majorities are
slim for democrats tied essentially in
the senate and only four in in the house
seems like a heavy lift what we're
hearing so far
yeah it does brett i think all these
problems they're running into with this
massive bill are a function of trying to
act as if you have a massive mandate
when you have basically no mandate at
all i mean this is really they really
have a staggeringly ambitious spending
agenda also social agenda um with a tied
senate and a tiny handful of votes in
their you know majority in the house um
it was probably never going to work and
it looks like it is not going to work
and the decision by the parliamentarian
was obvious and obviously correct so i
think that's where we are
ben
no mandate yeah
where does this go i mean uh you've got
the house essentially holding the other
bill the bipartisan infrastructure bill
hostage until they deal with the 3.5
trillion or at least that's how it sets
up right now
i think this is looking
like a rolling disaster and it's very
unfortunate for the bite administration
given that the white house is really
only going to get one bite
at the apple here it's kind of the uh
the skipping the step you know the how
many licks does it take to get to the
center of the tootsie pop
and i think that unfortunately here by
trying to cram so much into this package
they've created a scenario where there
are many moderates not just the ones
that we know about publicly who are not
going to go along with something this
massive and the other side as you uh as
you suggested the left is really not
satisfied with this that doesn't do as
much as they want it to do so i think
unfortunately this thing is rolling
towards a really hard brick wall
politically and it's probably going to
be the last major piece of legislation
they're able to get through
or get to this point before the midterms
yeah speaking of which senator bernie
sanders talking about this bill
the three and a half trillion is much
too low a compromise has already been
made an agreement has been made and the
american people by the way poll after
poll after poll are telling us
now is the time to stand up to powerful
special interests now is the time to
start representing working families on
all of these issues
now
senators mansion and cinema as ben
mentioned harold are the ones taking the
progressive fire but there are others
who have problems with this and not just
the overall price tag
so good to be with you i think democrats
in the congress have to remember
that for 40 years democrats controlled
the congress until 94
newt gingrich and republicans brought in
a revolution
and over the last 28 years the country
has enamored themselves with wanting
results
and they've changed the majority four
times democrats are in the majority now
democrats should take the victory that's
in front of them it's time to reset here
i listen to liberals i listen to the
moderates but more importantly i listen
to the country joe biden was elected
to unify the country and help stabilize
and bring us around an agenda that could
advance the country democrats would be
good to look to that and once you get a
victory then you figure out the the next
victory but democrats should democrats
liberal and moderate alike should
realize you could lose this majority and
you would deserve it if you don't take
the victory right in front of you and
live to fight in advance another day
trey you've seen speaker pelosi do these
legislative things where she herds the
cats and somehow manages to get the
votes on these big pieces of legislation
but as i said with brit it seems like
they're heading towards a corner here
well i can tell you bro she ain't gonna
hate her kirsten cinema and joe manchin
i mean she may can get the house
in order i'm not sure she can but i
guarantee you she's not going to get
senator sinema in order
harold is right it's a 50-50 country
bernie sanders was too crazy to even be
the nominee of the democrat party so why
would the entire country let him set the
agenda it's a narrow majority and
republicans would be wise to ask why is
elizabeth mcdonough having to save the
republic because you can't win a senate
seat in georgia that's why yeah then you
have the set up for this uh this rally
this weekend and and you just heard
howie's piece but take a listen to this
media build up
washington on high alert ahead of a
rally supporting rioters arrested in the
capital attack warnings of a serious set
of violence at tomorrow's rally in
washington d.c in support of the capital
insurrectionist the most dangerous
unknown tonight is what tomorrow may
bring authorities warning of threats of
violence and of concerning chatter on
the eve of a rally in support of
hundreds of people now charged in the
january sixth riot it was a fairly
paltry
uh turnout for the justice for january 6
rally they said maybe 700 would show it
pretty much fizzled
bret what about this
well
look this is the case of of the of the
authorities in washington having failed
to prepare for the january 6 rally
having decided they weren't going to
make that mistake again you know instead
of in a set of military generals that
they're always fighting the last war
well i guess you could say the same for
law enforcement officials involved in
this effort over the weekend they were
fighting the last war and what they got
was was some pale imitation of that
a pathetic little paltry turnout
unsupported by most republican or most
conservative organizations not even
supported or endorsed by donald trump it
was a fiasco yeah trey i mean at one
point there were about 30 photographers
around one guy with a flag
yeah i mean the first rally was a
criminal and constitutional disaster so
i'm not surprised that people didn't
show up for the second one the silver
lining is the media was there which
means they weren't at the enemies and
they weren't in a maskless indoor
environment and they got to meet some
cops before uh they're defunded so
that's the silver lining here's uh peter
ducey and jen saki today on this back
and forth about the border
is somebody asking the foreign nationals
who are walking into del rio texas and
setting up camps on this side of the
border for proof of vaccination or a
negative colbit test
as individuals come across the border
and
they are both assessed for whether they
have uh any symptoms if they have
symptoms they are the intention is for
them to be quarantined that is our
process they're not intending to stay
here for a lengthy period of time i
don't think it's the same thing it's not
the same thing we are expelling
individuals based on title 42
specifically because of covid
all right so harold um they're not
expecting to stay for a long period of
time well they're hoping to and
the department of homeland security
secretary down in del rio texas today
what do you make of it
that young ducey knows how to
dish out a ducey there i think that
there's no doubt democrats are in a
pickle on this one
we've got to get better control of the
border democrat and republican alike
don't quite understand the rules i think
at some point the president's going to
have to consider
uh changes in how personnel and other
things how you think about the governing
and the guidance down there the phone
name jay johnson who comes on this
network and other networks and i think
gives a pretty good take on these things
i would say though if press over hype
could stop violence we ought to send
them to philly in chicago and new york
and l.a every night too
ben i got 10 seconds here
uh i just think that the idea uh that in
intention is doing a lot of work in that
gensake response right there uh which is
not being delivered when it comes to the
actual border policy in practice
let me just say that manny pacquiao may
be the next president of the philippines
and for herb i'm very sorry that i
pronounced it the wrong way um
we'll get it right next time all right
panel stand by